mich
[Applaudissements]
avec beaucoup d'applaudissements quand
vous pouvez y constater la première fois
que les rénovations données présenter un
film à cannes en tant que réalisatrice
[Applaudissements]
d'applaudissements évidemment
entouré
de très très bons acteurs québécois
on n'est pas forcément périlleux dans
france mais ils sont connus dans leur
pays
un film pour découvrir à l'automne en
salle
[Applaudissements]
ouais
et comme savez bien l'habitude
les réalisateurs ont un petit mot à la
fin de la projection ça a été le cas
évidemment ballerini verticale ou
bipolaires
toute l'équipe
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup et j'ai une grande
grande chance d'avoir d'être entouré de
gens aussi talentueux généreux et très
heureux d'être là donc merci à vous
merci à toute l'équipe
merci à tous mon producteur merci merci
tout le monde on a je crois on a bien
travaillé
merci et merci m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]